hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and Alyssa and
Marie and we're gonna watch a trailer
for the flash the TV show and people are
raving about this [ __ ] now we got the
arrow we're getting Gotham
now we're getting what are you doing
you're distracting the audience from me
when I'm speaking I love you too but
honey we talked about this you're not
supposed to do that while we're filming
I love your face when you get like that
I know I didn't then fun stuff happens
get it no it's okay we're gonna watch
this trailer wait what is it I just said
what it was it's a flat yeah DC's going
into television a lot yeah I didn't um
station he's picked up a sherry that's
what this is my mom was murdered
all these comic book heroes get their
parents killed men like Jamie this is
Ida Lightning there was a man right
he kills my mom
the [ __ ] yeah duck get work so you can
go off chasing down this open the guys
always a cop why just this guy's really
freakin attractive
like my Greek whole life searching for
the impossible never imagining he's
gonna get hit with something this looks
like a really well-made show oh no but
he's gonna be okay guys need you to
urinate
who's happening what's going on you were
struck by lightning dude I mean nine
months welcome back mr. al hi guys good
actor to discuss
I watched you die Barry you can't die in
your heart still beating yes really fast
commands have had your guardian who
thought the world was slowing down you
were going so fast it only looked like
everyone else was standing still there's
so much that we don't understand you
can't say that nice to dislike so cool
searching for other metahumans the
dimensional barrier ruptured unleashing
unknown energies into our world
antimatter dark energy X elements are
all theoretical and how theoretical are
you
interesting question don't they get too
small
you know what under watch this I'm gonna
watch it see i'm gonna take time to
watch the show yeah yeah we have to stop
or just a head struck my life
who's that
Martinson water hero cooler yeah killing
off the black girls cooler
I need your help to catch Mardon I just
probably dead I can't do it without you
I have something that might help
reinforce it's a little cool guy who was
struck by lightning I don't because you
can inspire you by creating a universe
you know what we should get together
every night and this comes on yeah dude
this looks really well-made
like the effects are good
George's you've done
do not faster than a bullet
what happened to just your everyday pen
a bad guy shut up
ha no my name is Barry Allen and I am
the fastest man alive
a friend recently gave me the idea for
new name that something tells me it's
gonna catch up
the figured advice wear a mask
that's how you make an exit very cool
pointlessly flip off the river I think
this show is going to be a turning point
for the CW I think they're gonna start
to become a really big station yeah I
feel like a lot of these television
network like regularly Network channels
that are paying attention to what cable
shows do they're really up in their game
and their quality a lot input it looks
cool
good good fine Ian say anyway Murray
there's a shadow casting over you
because you're not in the frame there
you go I'm just gonna reiterate this
that for all those ladies watching that
guy is really attractive no I'd lick his
nipples you guys really look agreed upon
how fast you think the flash can [ __ ]
probably pretty fast because when girls
are like faster and it might be too fast
I'd be scared to have sex with flash
that's the point dude like ran a tornado
out of existence yeah yeah I don't want
to yeah yup see once you just fly away
standing in front of a train no yeah
scratch that off the bucket list
acting looks great the show looks
[ __ ] great I like everything about it
looks awesome great action great effects
which you don't see on a CW show so yeah
man
it's gonna be [ __ ] sweet I haven't
seen arrow but I hear it's really good
to start creating another good show in
the same universe is a smart idea
they're doing they're smart about this
they know Marvel rules movies so they're
gonna take over television this I think
is gonna be more popular than agents of
shield
I think so too now many people care
about agents of shield actually yeah and
I don't really care to know oh we talk
so much yeah if you're new to the
channel do that some fast it like
flashed on the screen no pun intended
this is nice Murray this is the longest
my arms ever been around you before
there we go killer whales rule for oh
yeah they do for ya dude he was born in
the year Ford and that's why you put his
name in there none of the girls were her
but she says he said Veronica and I are
a great couple you know who Veronica is
hot ass latina that's who she is and
yeah we are a great couple and I'm
telling you the intercourse we would
have would be amazing better than the
kind that I have with Elissa
here the person is no this is all
factual actually thanks killer whales
real for I wanted to share that secret
with you Tennessee Parker how are you
how are you can I see Parker you wanted
a shout-out I have a question for you
how do you pronounce your name is it
actually how he's saying it or not how
you think his name is pronounced yeah I
want all the comments to tell me how
Kenzie's name it's ke and es Yi no
[ __ ] connecting oh yeah I mean you
don't know community can easy he's my
favorite and is it Parker or is that
Park our we were all thank you that
we're not having sex anymore Elizabeth
Stefan is zhanka he said if you don't
shout me out I will get an Asian problem
star good to massage every inch of your
body what is a problem star I don't know
I think you please taking poor know what
he's like I'm gonna create Ryan a probe
out out so we could see what a problem
star is oh yeah dude and how is that a
threat that's that's like I'd rather not
show you out so I can get an Asian
problem star to massage every inch of my
body I'm imagining like some kind of
like this are throwing stars sort of
thing but like that just causes like
curse Keynesians inside every front of
your body but it's actually a nice yeah
agent problems too